>> Katie: PRESIDENT BIDEN
SETTING OFF THE LEFT, REJECTING
CALLS OVER THE WEEKEND, MORE
ENFORCEMENT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
DURING THE SURGE OF VIOLENT
CRIME.
>> 2020 WAS THE DEADLIEST YEAR
FOR A LAW ENFORCEMENT ON RECORD,
AND TODAY WE ARE HERE TO
REMEMBER NEARLY 500 OF YOUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
THERE WILL BE MORE RESOURCES,
NOT FEWER RESOURCES TO HELP YOU
DO YOUR JOB, THAT'S WHY I
PROPOSE WE INVEST AGAIN IN
COMMUNITY POLICING, ONE THING
THAT PROTECTS COPS OR OTHER
COPS.
>> Katie: THAT'S A CONVENIENT
NARRATIVE NOW, WOULD'VE BEEN
BETTER OFF LAST SUMMER WHEN THIS
WHOLE CRIME SURGE STARTED.
>> Greg: OCCURRING DURING
NATIONAL POLICE WEEK, THE CNN
COVERS IT AS THE NATIONAL WEEK
OF WHITE SUPREMACY.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US IN THE
REAL WORLD, BUT WHERE WERE YOU
WENT TO WERE BURNING AND COPS
WERE GETTING ATTACKED?
HE CANNOT TAKE THE STAND BECAUSE
IT ALIGNED HIMSELF WITH HIS
TRUMP, SO HE LET POLITICS
REPLACE HIS SPINE AND RAKE
RETREATED TO HIS BASEMENT.
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WORTH OF DAMAGE AND PEOPLE
DYING, COPS COMMITTING SUICIDE
AND THE ONLY REASON WHY HE IS
TALKING ABOUT IT NOW IS BECAUSE
IT'S A POLITICAL WEAPON TO USE
AGAINST THE WEAPON TO
JANUARY 6TH, AND THE
INCONSISTENCY AT THE TRUTH, DID
NOT GIVE A DAMN ABOUT COPS
BEFORE JANUARY 6TH, NOW HE DOES.
I KNOW THAT I SHOULD BE MORE
DIPLOMATIC IN SAYING THAT I AM
GLAD THAT HE FINALLY CAME
AROUND, BUT I'M SO CYNICAL AT
THIS POINT BECAUSE HE DIDN'T DO
JACK FOR SO LONG, IT ACTUALLY
INFURIATES ME.
AND IT'S HARD TO THEM.
DANA.
>> Dana: I KNOW COMING OUT OF
A VERY, CALM PRESENCE.
>> Greg: I'M VERY MAD RIGHT
NOW, VERY MAD.
>> Katie: BUT DEMOCRATS WERE
GETTING DESTROYED WHEN IT CAME
TO THE DEFUND OF POLICE ISSUE IN
THE SENATE RACE IN VIRGINIA
HOUSE RACES, SO IS THIS A WAY TO
KIND OF CHANGE THE NARRATIVE
AHEAD OF 2022?
>> Dana: I THINK IN THE WAY
THAT ONE OF THE REASONS IT IS
CYNICAL AND FRUSTRATING COMING
YOU BELIEVE THAT THAT IS THE
REAL JOE BIDEN SPEAKING COMING
GO BACK TO 1994 IN THE CRIME
BILL AND THINGS HE HAS HAD IN
THE PAST FOR POLICE AND THERE IS
A POLITICAL MOMENT AND HE DID
NOT STAND UP WHEN WE NEEDED HIM
TO, SO THESE PEOPLE, WILL THE
REAL JOE BIDEN PLEASE STAND UP,
IF CRIME IS IN THE HEADLINE, HE
KNOWS THAT HE IS LOSING BECAUSE
IT IS SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY
WILL PAY ATTENTION TO IN THE
FIRST STORY THAT WILL ALWAYS GET
COVERED IS GOING TO BE CRIME, SO
LIKE INSPECTOR GADGET, THE
MESSAGE IS SELF-DESTRUCTING AND
NOT JUST ON THIS ISSUE, IT'S
ALSO HAPPENING ON IMMIGRATION
AND WHAT HAPPENED THIS WEEKEND,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SAYS
THAT THEY WILL RETURN IN THE
MEXICO POLICY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS IN THE
LEFT-WING PEOPLE ON THE ZOOM
CALL WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WALKED OUT OF THE
MEETING.
THEY FOUND OUT THIS WEEK THAT
IT'S LIKELY THAT THE CLIMATE
PROPOSAL AND THE BIG
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL ARE GOING TO
BE PULLED OUT AS THEY ARE
DEJECTED OVER THAT.
THEY ARE DEPRESSED BECAUSE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO DELIVER ON THE VOTING
RIGHTS BILL THEY WANTED TO PASS,
ALL OF THIS LEADING TO THE
PRESIDENT MAY BE DOING
SOMETHING.
SPIN ON THE SPEECH FROM
PRESIDENT BIDEN OVER THE WEEKEND
HAD A LOT OF NICE THINGS HE
SAID, BUT PERSONNEL IS POLICY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT DOJ AND KRISTEN
CLARKE, THE PEOPLE WHO CALLED TO
DEFEND THE POLICE SAYING THE
WHOLE SYSTEM IS RACIST, THOSE
ARE THE ONES RUNNING THE SHOW
WHEN IT COMES TO INVESTIGATIONS
AND POLICIES ON A FEDERAL LEVEL
FOR A POLICE DEPARTMENT'S ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND THEY HAVE NOT
OFFERED MUCH IN TERMS OF BACKING
THE POLICE IN THE WAY THAT THE
PRESIDENT CALLED FOR.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHY PEOPLE
THINK HE HAS A PUPPET, BECAUSE
HE DOES NOT CALL HIS OWN PEOPLE
THAT HAVE THESE STABS, HE WAS
ANTICRIME IN THE '90s AND THEN
AFTER FLOYD, HE SAID, OH, WE
HAVE SYSTEMIC RACISM IN THE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS, BUT WE
SHOULD REDIRECT FUNDING FROM THE
POLICE AND HIDDEN SILENCE IN THE
BASEMENT, THEN WHEN YOU SEE THEM
LOSE THE HOUSE IN NOVEMBER
BECAUSE OF THIS, HE TRIED TO
TALK BACK AGAIN, THAT'S WHY NO
ONE TRUST HIM.
HE IS NOT EVEN PUSHED HIS
ANTI-CRIME AND POLICE REFORM
BILLS THROUGH CONGRESS.
HE CONTROLS BOTH HOUSES AND ARE
DOA, POLICE DEPARTMENTS NEED
STRONG LEADERSHIP AND VOCAL
SUPPORT FROM THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF, BECAUSE THEY ARE PUTTING
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE OF
MAKING SPLIT-SECOND CALLS,
CALLED PURSUITS, FOOT PURSUITS
COME DEALING WITH SOME OF THE
MOST HORRIFIC PEOPLE AS GREG
SAYS, PEOPLE ON THEIR WORST DAYS
IN AMERICA, AND THEY ARE JUST
GOING TO RETIRE.
TO STICK AROUND AND STAY IN
THEIR SQUAD CARS AND NOT DO
PROACTIVE POLICING IF THEY ARE
NOT GETTING VOCAL SUPPORT FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE, AND THAT'S WHAT
WE ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW.
HE HAS TO CONVINCE HIS PARTY TO
BE LESS ANTI-POLICE IF HE IS
GOING TO STAND A SHOT FOR PEOPLE
TO BELIEVE IN.
>> Katie: ONE OF THE GUYS THAT
PUTS THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE ARE
GETTING FIRED BECAUSE THEY WON'T
APPLY THE VACCINE MANDATE, WHAT
IS THE PLAN TO HINDER THIS NEW
CRIME WAVE?
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO ABOUT
IT?
>> Richard: I'M NOT A
LAWMAKER, BUT WHAT CAN BE DONE,
IT'S NOT ABOUT DEFUNDING THE
POLICE, OR THE DEMAND A POLICY
OF THE HASHTAG, WHAT WE HAVE TO
DO IS ONE END BAD POLICING
PRACTICES LIKE STOPPING FOR THE
PROFILING AND THE EXCESSIVE OVER
POLICING AND ACTUALLY FOCUS ON
HOW WE DO POLICING BETTER COME
BECAUSE WHAT YOU HAVE --
>> Katie: WHAT ABOUT THE
CRIMINALS?
US BEFORE HE IS TALKING ABOUT
THE CRIMINALS.
A >> Richard: SAID NOTHING
LIKE THAT.
>> Greg: BUT YOU DID THAT WISH
LIST.
>> Richard: EXCUSE ME.
>> Jesse: SHE ASKED YOU HOW
YOU DEAL WITH CRIME AND HE WENT
AFTER THE POLICE.
A >> Richard: I'M GETTING
THERE, YOU TALK TO COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND BLACK COMMUNITIES,
WHAT THEY TELL YOU IS THAT 64%
OF THEM FAVORS STREET PATROLS,
60% OF THEM FAVOR MORE MONEY
GOING THROUGH WORD FORM AND
TRAINING AND YOU ALSO HAVE
COMMUNITIES THAT SAY THERE IS A
FEAR AND MISTRUST WHEN IT COMES
TO POLICE AND POLICE CANNOT BE
AFFECTED IF THE PEOPLE WHO THEY
NEED TO BE EFFECTIVE TOWARDS
DON'T TRUST THEM, SO WHAT YOU
HAVE TO DO IS HAVE REFORM IN
PLACE SO THAT WHEN YOU CALL 911
YOU ARE GOING TO TRUST THE
PERSON ON THE OTHER END OF THE
PHONE.
AND WHEN COMMUNITIES DON'T TRUST
WHO IS ON THE OTHER END OF THE
PHONE WHO WILL SHOW UP WHEN THEY
CALL 911 WE HAVE A PROBLEM.
AND UNTIL WE ARE WILLING TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEIR PROBLEM
EXISTS, WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE CIRCULAR CONVERSATION THAT
GETS US NOWHERE WHICH IS WHERE
WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
>> Katie: I DON'T THINK THAT
WE ARE IN A CIRCULAR
CONVERSATION?
>> Richard: THAT'S EXACTLY
WHERE WE ARE, REPUBLICANS
BELIEVE ONE THING, DEMOCRATS
BELIEVE SOMETHING ELSE.
>> Greg: THERE ARE SO MANY
OPTION